Sud Radio parlant vrai chez Bourdin
10h30 12h30 Jean-Jacques Bourdin
nous recevons Éric Ciotti le président
des républicains qui ne sait pas
exprimer depuis le début de la semaine
Éric Ciotti bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous jusqu'à 12h30 sur l'antenne de
Sud Radio j'ai plein de questions à vous
poser et notamment évidemment sur la
réforme des retraites des bas à
l'Assemblée nationale depuis lundi
faisons le point 61 député combien selon
vous voteront la réforme aujourd'hui
pour être clair je pense que les deux
tiers du groupe sont dans une position
de soutenir une réforme nécessaire
cohérente avec ce qu'on a toujours dit
et responsable par rapport à la
situation du pays il y a une vingtaine
de députés que je comprends qui ont des
interrogations qui ont des doutes qui se
disent
le moment est mal choisi si on en est là
c'est parce que de nous payons les
erreurs qui ont été fait par le pouvoir
en place depuis 2017 le fait qu'on a
dépensé sans compter le fait qu'il n'y
ait pas eu de réforme mais que donc elle
est plus plus dure aujourd'hui le fait
que la situation des Français face à la
crise sanitaire d'abord il y a quelques
mois face à la crise énergétique face à
la crise du pouvoir d'achat
suicide beaucoup de colère et
d'inquiétude d'angoisse dans le pays les
députés l'entendent donc nous portons et
j'essaie de trouver cette voie qui soit
cohérent avec ce que nous avons toujours
dit est fait c'est à dire la nécessité
de sauver le système par répartition je
vous rappelle que le système par
répartition c'est le général de Gaulle
le lendemain de la guerre qu'il a voulu
c'est une solidarité entre génération ça
veut dire que tout le monde a droit à
une retraite mais ceux qui travaillent
aujourd'hui paix la retraite de ceux qui
ont travaillé hier qui eux-mêmes
payaient la retraite de leurs parents
c'est un système qui est juste il faut
le sauver aujourd'hui en péril pourquoi
parce que l'évolution démographique
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie le
vieillissement le fait qu'on est plus
longtemps et c'est heureux c'est un
progrès à la retraite et le fait qui est
moins d'actif pour payer les retraites
il faut travailler un peu plus donc si
on ne veut juste pour vous la réforme
est juste je dirais pas qu'elle est
juste telle qu'elle a été faite elle est
nécessaire d'abord elle est nécessaire
autrement Jean-Jacques Bourdin qu'est-ce
qui se passera oui dans 5 à 10 ans le
niveau des retraites va s'effondrer mais
moi je m'y refuse je refuse de voir le
contrat de confiance passé avec nos
aînés s'effondrer ou même ceux qui vont
rentrer à la retraite demain dire qu'ils
vont voir le corps a cité un chiffre
pour les années c'est très loin
2070 en disant que le taux de
remplacement c'est à dire la pension de
retraite par rapport au dernier salaire
serait à peine un tiers ça veut dire
qu'on est tension baisse
structurellement donc je veux éviter
cette baisse comme je veux éviter c'est
une autre solution d'ailleurs certains
partis à gauche
la propose c'est à dire on augmente les
cotisations sur les retraites ça veut
dire quoi qu'on baissera les salaires et
le pouvoir d'achat et donc il y a une
voix médiane qui est celle de dire on
travaille un peu plus bien sûr ces
douloureux mais je pense que c'est la
voie de la raison donc une vingtaine de
députés aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ne
voterai pas de député LR ou
s'absiendrait où
émouvant
on l'a vu dans les votes à l'Assemblée
bon le patron des sénateurs républicains
Bruno retaillod a déclaré ce matin
c'était sur RTL l'avenir de la droite se
joue dans ce débat je pense que l'on
peut mourir de nos contradictions je
vais y revenir dans un instant juste
après la pub Éric Ciotti à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
Sud Radio parlant vrai chez Bourdin
10h30 12h30 Jean-Jacques Bourdin Éric
cioti président des républicains eriki
vous avez à côté de vous un
vice-président exécutif des républicains
donc qui est à vos côtés qui dit le
contraire de vous en ce qui concerne la
réforme des retraites c'est Aurélien
Pradier je je
le cite s'il se sent vraiment de notre
famille politique qui donne un moment
prendre la décision de voter la loi ça
c'est pas lui ça c'est le président du
Sénat qui a déclaré ça que dit Aurélien
Pradier nous refusons de soutenir une
réforme qui pénalise les Français qui
travaillent le plus dur et il ajoute le
courage politique ce n'est pas vouloir
faire du mal aux Français voilà ce qu'il
dit que lui répondez-vous ce matin mon
rôle ma mission elle est pas simple
cette fixer une ligne qui est la ligne
de notre famille politique je le redis
mais pour moi ce mot est extrêmement
important en cohérence
avec ce qu'a toujours dit fait et ce
qu'est la droite républicaine la droite
républicaine c'est le parti du travail
c'est le parti du courage c'est le parti
de la responsabilité
l'état du pays et ce que je condamne
chez Manuel Macron c'est de ne pas
l'avoir fait plus tôt et de réformer
d'arrêter cette dérive qui fait qu'on a
3000 milliards d'euros de dettes qu'on a
160 milliards d'euros de déficit
budgétaires connaissent 64 milliards
d'euros de déficit commercial et que
finalement depuis 6 ans on est resté
impuissant j'ai rajouté les 5 ans entre
avec Hollande donc il y a cette
nécessité donc moi je fixe cette ligne
après on n'est pas une caserne et puis
on n'est pas d'accord au départ
Jean-Jacques Bourdin on n'est pas au
terme fixé une ligne et être totalement
désaccord avec la ligne fixée on verra
au terme du débat le terme vous ce matin
pour l'instant Aurélien Pradier dans les
votes que nous avons n'a pas émis de
votre contradictoire je le souligne à
l'Assemblée nationale il exprime une
voie moi je suis pas là pour faire taire
tel ou tel expression je suis là pour
fixer une ligne qui conforme à celle sur
laquelle j'ai été lu moi je suis de
droite je le disais l'autre soir dans le
débat monsieur Bardella ce qui nous
différencie avec Monsieur Bardella c'est
que moi je suis de droite et je les
redis à certaines de mes collègues et la
droite pour moi ce sont des valeurs et
au premier rang d'entraîne c'est la
responsabilité la valeur du travail là
où certains prennent prônent aujourd'hui
l'éloge de la paresse quand on est
droite voilà dire qu'il faut travailler
un peu plus c'est douloureux ça
nécessite des efforts je le mesure je le
comprends j'entends la colère mais ce
qui m'importe c'est l'intérêt supérieur
du pays ça peut juste d'autres de mes
collègues disent il faut s'opposer à une
réforme à la question non pas la
question mais à celui qui la pose c'est
à dire à Emmanuel Macron j'entends aussi
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de motifs qui
nous mettent en colère face à la
politique actuelle mais je dis à cela et
je pense que je vais les convaincre
regardons l'intérêt supérieur du pays ce
qui est bon pour la France demain on
nous jugera dans 10 ans sur ceux qui ont
eu le courage de la réforme ou pas
je discute avec lui moi il y a aucune ou
case j'entends toutes les voix en moment
on fictionne cap une direction on l'a
fait avec Olivier marlex on est en phase
avec nos collègues du du Sénat et vous
verrez à la sortie on est dans les
débats on se retrouve à tous sur le
chemin de la réforme nécessaire et utile
pour le périple hier vous vous êtes
réunis avec Gérard Larcher avec Olivier
Marleix qui est le patron des députés à
l'Assemblée avec Bruno Retailleau qui
est le patron des députés au Sénat vous
avez évoqué évidemment le cas Aurélien
Pradier pour l'instant
sa volonté de ne pas voter cette réforme
bon imaginons qu'il ne la vote pas que
se passe-t-il qu'il va être contre
vous rendez compte dans votre famille
politique vous êtes président et votre
vice-président votre compte que se
passe-t-il mais il votera cette réforme
ah voilà alors
vous l'avez écoutez il votera la réforme
c'est c'est un défi pour moi oui que
tout le monde soit dans l'esprit de
cohérence voilà donc pourquoi dites-vous
cela
Pradier d'ailleurs aujourd'hui je le
cite il a il a donné une interview
Figaro il dit les choses très clairement
ce que dit Aurélien Pradier et on peut
et on peut l'entendre avec certaines
limites qui ne sont qui sont celles de
ne pas détricoter l'esprit de la réforme
pour maintenir l'équilibre parce que si
on fait une réforme pour qu'elle ne
rapporte rien bien sûr que les Français
ne peuvent pas comprendre moi je veux
qu'il y ait une réforme pour sauver le
système de retraite par répartition dans
quelques années et pour pas qu'on baisse
les retraites au royaume Pradier dit et
ça s'entend il faut pas que ceux qui
commencer à travailler le plus tôt ce
qu'on appelle les carrières longues
cotise le plus longtemps c'est à dire
aujourd'hui c'était 44 ans
les carrières longues c'est Jacques
Chirac et François Fillon dans la
réforme de 2003 qu'il avait négocié avec
la CFDT c'est un principe qui atténuait
la brutalité du d'une forme peut-être le
caractère trop dur que certains estiment
la réforme aujourd'hui nous disons tous
ceux qui ont travaillé avant 21 ans ne
doivent pas cotiser plus de 43 ans parce
que ils ont commencé tôt quelques fois
très tôt il y en a 15 ans il y en a 16
ans pas beaucoup mais il y en a beaucoup
à 17 18 c'est un point qui reste en
débat puisque la première ministre nous
a rajouté une tranche celle des 20-21 et
c'est bien c'est le succès de notre
famille politique il y a encore ce débat
si ce débat est réglé nous serons tous
nous serons tous d'accord
pour expliquer aux auditeurs proposent
je gère la famille un trimestre de
cotisation avant 21 ans pour bénéficier
du système de carrière longue non est-ce
que ça vous paraît raisonnable ce n'est
plus ce qui propose ah bon voilà il est
il est revenu un peu en arrière il parle
il parle de l'application
d'une durée maximale de cotisation à 43
ans pour tous ceux qui sont dans le cas
d'une carrière l'homme c'est à dire la
définition de la carrière longue voulue
par Jacques Chirac en 2005 et 5
trimestres ou 5 4 si on a commencé à
travailler à la fin de l'année autrement
c'est 5 trimestres voilà donc ça
maintenant j'ai encore de discuter avec
Aurélien Pradier quasiment cette nuit
enfin c'était nous étions de nuit
jusqu'à minuit à l'Assemblée jusqu'au
terme vous avez parlé voilà
j'entends sa position moi je lui dis
simplement nous sommes de droite nous
sommes cohérents nous sommes
responsables une réforme elle doit être
elle doit aboutir à un gain aussi qui
budgétaire malheureusement je dirais
pour sauver le système on a obtenu des
avancées moi vous savez j'étais plutôt
au départ sur les 65 ans mais d'abord
j'ai voulu qu'on soit cohérent avec le
Sénat qui avait proposé chaque année un
amendement 64 j'ai voulu j'ai mesuré
aussi qu'il fallait pas que cette
réforme soit trop brutale d'un coup
pourquoi un année-là parce que depuis
2017 je le redis mais c'est essentiel on
a rien fait donc on arrive monsieur
Macron arrive au pied du mur et la pente
pour sauter ce mur que subissent les
Français elle est plus raide donc moi
j'ai voulu atténuer cette brutalité
comment bien on est passé de 65 à 64 on
a pris en compte aussi c'était pour nous
essentiel le fait qu'on revalorise les
petites retraites parce qu'il y a des
Français qui ont des retraites indignes
ça a été fait 1200 euros brut c'est un
pas important on le doit aux
républicains nous avons fait une propose
aussi importante c'est de dire il y aura
pas de hold-up tel que le gouvernement
le prévoyait sur les fonds de réserves
des régimes complémentaires les régimes
complémentaires agir Carco ils sont très
bien gérés d'ailleurs c'est un exemple
pour l'étape parce que ce sont les
partenaires sociaux qui gèrent le Medef
les syndicats qui gèrent ils agissent il
y a 70 milliards d'euros d'excédents
donc ça veut dire que ça marche et
l'État voulait faire un petit
prélèvement ou même gros là dessus on
l'a empêché on a une clause de revoyure
en 2010 en 2027 donc on a eu ces
avancées il reste des points sur les
femmes notamment sur la carrière des
mers plutôt que les femmes je les femmes
bien sûr mais les maires de famille si
les amendements sont discutés parce que
là ça dépend du calendrier bon
évidemment
Erik sotti deux mots d'ailleurs mais je
voudrais encore parce que je suis à
cette étude vous le savez vous me
connaissez bien Aurélien Poitiers
de notre groupe si nous obtenons
satisfaction sur ce point je vous dis il
veut je suis convaincu qu'il votera
cette retraite c'est mon travail
mais
il défend il défendent
franchement
ils sont respectables voilà oui oui dans
la vie politique
2027 dans la vie politique qui ne veut
pas se faire connaître c'est pas moi qui
voilà bon ceux qui celui qui prétendait
le côté le contraire serait abordé par
une forme d'hypocrisie quoi
il défendent et ils défendent des
convictions il y a des points sur
lesquels moi je lui ai dit j'ai dit
attention il y a des lignes aussi et
pour moi il y a des lignes très claires
on est dans une famille de droite et la
droite c'est pas la gauche
une fibre sociale d'autres l'ont eu
rappelons vous
rappelons-nous ce qui avait porté
Jacques Chirac sur tel ou tel sujet mais
la droite elle doit être de droite alors
Éric Ciotti est-ce que vous craignez je
change un peu je vais quitter Aurélien
Pradier bon pas il va pas nous occuper
toute la matinée vous occupe beaucoup la
nuit apparemment mais bon non un mot sur
la suite maintenant est-ce que est-ce
que vous pensez qu'il peut y avoir
un blocage du pays et est-ce que la
situation aujourd'hui vous inquiète je
vous pose franchement la question la
situation bien sûr m'inquiète parce que
je sens de l'attention dans le pays oui
je sors de l'an la colère j'ai rappelé
tout à l'heure tous les facteurs
d'inquiétudes quand on voit des petits
commerçants des boulangers qui qui
obligé de fermer parce qu'il y a un
explosion de leur tarif d'électricité
je l'espère pas mais je l'espère pas
pour ça que toutes les voix et je
regrette que le gouvernement
contrairement à ce qu'avait fait Nicolas
Sarkozy en 2010 n'est pas maintenu il y
avait des oppositions en 2010 il y avait
du monde dans la rue oui il y avait
toujours un dialogue moi quand j'ai reçu
les syndicats j'ai rencontré Laurent
Berger j'ai rencontré le patron de la
CFE-CGC François hollyle comme j'ai
rencontré comme j'ai rencontré aussi les
responsables Geoffroy route Bézieux ou
monsieur Hasselin de la CPME mais
en tout cas les syndicats me disent en
2010 on était opposés aussi à la réforme
courageuse et du président Sarkozy de
François Fillon mais on discutait et là
j'ai l'impression que tout dialogue au
gouvernement de prendre langue avec les
réunir c'est pas moi de réunir une
conférence quand aujourd'hui avec le
patronat et les syndicats moi quand on
n'est pas d'accord c'est jamais
utile de discuter vous vous évoluez nos
différents beaucoup plus modeste mais
dans notre famille politique il faut
toujours dire discuter faut aller au
bout et après il faut trancher moi je
souhaite je le dis que la réforme ait
lieu parce qu'elle est nécessaire il ne
faut pas céder sur certains principes
parce qu'autrement si on cède on a plus
de retraite par répartition alors
Eric Ciotti j'ai une dernière mdr on va
s'amuser un peu pour terminer ce matin
nous avions Jordan Bardella c'est
Patrick Roger qui est recevait Jordan
Bardella il a parlé de vous écoutant on
peut mettre ce en échec si les
oppositions se rassemblent or comme la
nupestre ne veut pas voter que le
rassemblement national parce que parce
qu'ils sont ce sont des gens sectaires
évidemment que ça arrange et ça avantage
le gouvernement sans compter que de
l'autre côté on a la voiture balai du
gouvernement avec les LR et probablement
monsieur sciatique qui rêve d'être
secrétaire d'État de Monsieur Attal lui
carrément il va matin
vous savez monsieur Bardella m'a dit la
même chose j'ai débattu avec lui l'autre
soir sur le plateau de France 2 et je
lui ai dit chose très simple dit que la
différence entre lui et moi c'est que
moi je suis droite moi je n'ai pas
consigné enfin je n'ai pas déposé un
amendement qui propose de maintenir le
régime spécial de la RATP et il y a deux
amendements à l'Assemblée nationale il y
en a un du groupe du Rassemblement
national pour dire il faut maintenir le
régime spécial de la RATP c'est à dire
que le chauffeur de bus parisien il part
10 ans plus tôt que le chauffeur de bus
niçois ou ou lyonnais ou marseillais et
il y en a un autre qui est déposé par
Monsieur Ruffin et tous les insoumis et
bien moi quand je vois
l'irresponsabilité de ce projet le c'est
quoi le projet du rassemblement national
sur les retraites il coûte je crois 37
milliards d'euros et celui des insoumis
60 ce n'est pas responsable moi je suis
pour dire la vérité je suis pour le
courage pas pour la démagogie permanente
bien sûr que c'est plus facile de dire
aux Français vous travaillez moins vous
partez à 60 ans la retraite à 60 ans
elle a coûté 2000 milliards d'euros au
pays on aurait quasiment
deux tiers de dette en moins aujourd'hui
voilà merci aimer il faut dire la vérité
il faut être courageeux c'est bien le
lot de tout le monde merci et erikiotti
d'être venu nous voir sur Sud Radio ce
matin il est 12h28 André mer